welcome to your mom's house
what makes you think I want to get in
there if it's covered in muddle it's not
about you it's muddy it's smelly by the
way your birthday happy Smurf day thanks
what was really nice I really
appreciated this we were laying in bed
and you lifted your legs you're on your
back and you lifted your two legs up
like a baby diaper change and then you
farted and you were wearing nothing but
boxers you ripped one and then you
rolled over and you go so what's up am i
gonna throw you the d today or what I
don't sit on this D no I didn't I go
really you're gonna after you farted on
me I said how about a blowjob right do
you think that was the appropriate time
to ask for something like that yeah
because that there was no fart in there
anymore I was gone now so now you know
I'm not gonna fart during a good day
because but why the theatrics I mean if
you wanted me to touch your D yeah why
the theatrics of pulling your legs
behind your ears in your boxer shorts
like you you went out of your way to be
disgusting I wasn't trying to be
disgusting I was trying to you know it's
going to be comical about it
entertaining I don't want you just hear
a boring fart like I hear those all the
time trying to give you something cool
to listen to can we talk about the fart
I had yesterday on the couch which one
the one that you were like that really
smells like poison is we had two mommy
yeah it's very rich it's very it's very
heavy I got the truffle burger you know
which makes a bad smell on the way out
I did a heavy bag workout after we had
those oh my god you wanna throw up no
cuz it had already settled but it really
made the brown come out really oh yeah
it was it the Umami Burger that made the
brown or the the heavy bag it was the
fitness it was the food but the
combination I think of a rich burger and
a pretty intense cardio workout you're
gonna Brown every time there's just no
way around it did you so which bathroom
did you use the Jews a bidet of course
okay of course I really prefer the
downstairs bidet it's warmer and
stronger
I need to I can't we get warm water
upstairs a cold stream it's not the same
it's a fucking fire hose downstairs here
it's so strong my asshole hurts I know I
kind of like it and it's like the seats
super warm now I'm telling you I've gone
I've even incorporated a little bit of
your action I haven't got even up gone
shit a button you know yeah that's what
I did wait a minute wait a minute are
you saying that you don't shit and then
go straight to wash sometimes I go wipe
one wipe first why does it get some of
the general mud out you're crazy
I think you're wasting toilet paper at
this point you need to go straight to
water hmm
to hose yeah and then it takes it off
like paint you know power water cold
water doesn't work the same cold water
doesn't work the same it's got to be not
the same Lena yeah how was the movie key